ein dreirad mitten auf der straße der
fahrer unauffindbar ein fall für die
polizei bad brückenau
wir waren ganz normal auf seife spot
hohe 30 in der nacht bevor man auch mal
die wohngebiete ab und dann guckt man
einfach mal ob alles in ordnung ist und
man dann hier die straße entlang
gefahren sind stand eben dieses dreirad
auf der fahrbahn
und dann haben wir schon gleich gedacht
das kann gar nicht sein da man es mal
tätig werden
die ermittlungen werden aufgenommen der
täter wird schnell gefunden und alter
schützt vor strafe nicht die polizei
greift knallhart durch
auch gleich entschieden da kommt eine
verwarnung hin ein sogenanntes ticket
wie wir das in bayern und war auch
gleich ein tatbestand gefunden
unbeleuchtet und nicht verkehrssicher
auf fahrbahn geparkt war da noch zu
finden der verwarnungs satz da waren uns
auch gleich einig eine tüte bonbons
daher vermutlich der fahrzeugführer oder
halter wohl doch ein etwas jüngerer sein
muss und die zuckersüße strafe wurde
natürlich gezahlt für das
vorschriftswidrige parken ihres dreirads
müssen die eltern der kleinen katharina
ordentlich in die zuckerdose greifen
das wird katharina bestimmt eine lehre
sein mal wieder hat das zuerst nicht
ganz verstanden was für diese straße
eigentlich gemeint war aber den wie er
dann erklärt haben dass man das leider
hat dann doch lieber sicher abstellen
sollte in zukunft haben uns darauf
geeinigt das ehepaar gehört dieses mal
ist die familie hahn stein noch mit
einem blauen auge davon gekommen
dem polizeibesuch werden sie bestimmt
nicht so schnell vergessen